et
[Musique]
les shadoks de la lune pompe
intellectuellement gégène fait son
jardin
les marins shadoks s'amusent comme des
poissons dans l'eau il n'y a que chez
les gimmicks de cela ne va pas pourquoi
au début
l'egypte y avait trouvé la terre bien
amusante parce qu'elle tournait et
chaque fois que la terre faisaient un
tour ils faisaient une il y avait la
fête du premier tour peut commencer le
matin jusqu'au soir
il y avait ensuite la fête du second
tour qui n'était pas la même mais qui
durait tout autant et puis les fêtes du
troisième du quatrième du 5e tour et
ainsi de suite et ainsi tout le reste du
temps une réfléchissait à de difficiles
problèmes de botanique ou de
météorologie avec leur chapeau
mais à la fin à force de trouver des
solutions a tellement de problèmes
difficiles les problèmes eux-mêmes
commencèrent à se faire rares et les jbe
se disait des solutions on en a toujours
ce qui nous manque le plus maintenant ce
sont les problèmes et les gibiers à
travers une première maladie de la terre
il commençait
son et puis n'est fait non plus au bout
d'un certain temps ça ne les intéressait
plus tôt il était devenu tellement
ado long qu'ils avaient chargé des
shadoks prisonniers de s'amuser à leur
place il les regardait et ça leur suffit
alors il leur criais gégène on joue plus
aujourd'hui ça va pas ou quoi
si si ça va il disait demain tu verras
on s'amusera et le lendemain arrivée et
au samedi
petit à petit ils trouvèrent que les
fleurs et les glace au chocolat n'avait
plus tout à fait le même coup que les
étés n'était plus aussi bon contre x et
que souvent il faisait froid
petit à petit ils trouvèrent que les
feuilles sont plus souvent par terre que
sur les branches des marronniers les jib
ils ne savaient pas encore qu'ils
avaient attrapé une autre maladie de la
terre une maladie qu'il ne connaissait
pas parce que sur leur planète là bas
c'était une maladie qui n'existait pas
il y avait que les jbe commençait à
vieillir
et oui c'est des choses qui arrivent sur
la terre
et
[Musique]